the i-team is learning a lot more about
the suspect involved in this vanessa
murphy is standing by in the studio
with more on that
joe we've learned the suspect is
60-year-old douglas claiborne who has a
lengthy criminal history that's
according to sources
his attorney tells me he would go back
and forth from hawaii to las vegas
his father tells me the clark county
coroner contacted his family
and he also expressed sorrow for what
happened
witnesses watched this police chase
unfold on interstate 15 in las vegas
tuesday
the i-team has learned the driver is
identified as 60-year-old douglas
claiborne
according to nevada highway patrol he
had stolen the car
trooper michael may was putting stop
sticks on the road when claiborne hit
him
trooper may went through the windshield
claiborne didn't stop until the car was
round
oh my god i don't know they shoot oh my
god
oh my god they shooting claiborne was
shot and killed by police
trooper may was carried by fellow
officers to this metro helicopter
and taken to university medical center
police union leader rick mccann says
officers at the scene
believed claiborne may have been
reaching for trooper may's weapon
after he had gone through the windshield
at that point in time
the officers involved apparently opened
fire i'm sure believing that either
their lives the troopers lives or the
community's lives
were at stake at risk and that's what
they're trained to do
claiborne has a lengthy criminal history
spanning multiple states including
nevada iowa texas and hawaii
his father and attorney both tell the
i-team he struggled with the drug
methamphetamine for years here's a mug
shot from 2007
in dallas compared to this one from 2020
in clark county
16 months ago just as the covid 19
pandemic was hitting las
vegas police say claiborne spit in an
officer's face
he was taken into custody at the palazzo
and accused of battery
court records reveal the clark county
district attorney's office declined to
move forward with the case his attorney
also confirms previous arrests for
robbery
assault making a terror threat abusing
family and felony drug
charges according to records he was
released from federal prison in 2019
after he was part of a plan with a
corrections officer and his brother
to smuggle drugs into a jail claiborne's
father says he believes his son
must have been on meth during his
alleged crime rampage
tuesday whoever was driving was trying
to pull the body still in the car
yeah claiborne's father
and attorney both tell me claiborne had
money
his lawyer says he was the beneficiary
of a trust fund and at one point he
drove
a porsche but he also says the drugs
took over now if he had survived tuesday
he'd likely be accused of trying to take
an
officer's life